[MUSIC]
Current trends are very clear.
First of all, it's easier and and
easier for companies to gather data.
So, there's this big data movement and
that doesn't appear to be
slowing down anytime soon.
Number two, currently,
advertisers can already engage in
personalized advertising or
dynamic creatives.
The underlying idea is that well,
since I know some information about this
consumer, what he or she likes to buy?
What types of preferences they have?
Maybe this is based on browsing history,
maybe purchase history, maybe zip code.
All these things
are observable online today.
Why don't I use that information
to cater my message,
to tailor my message to
that particular user?
And so, we wanted to understand
where are we headed.
Where we will be in say, ten years time?
[MUSIC]
There's a reason that advertisers
will do what they're doing and
there's a reason consumers will buy or
not.
And so, game theory allows us to
incorporate consumer incentives and
advertiser's incentives into the model.
First of all, the advertiser can
collect information about consumer,
then the advertiser can send a message
that can rely on that information or
not and the consumer can decide
whether to buy or not, for example.
So this could be anything,
could be a dealership trying to
attract a consumer for a test drive.
It could be a realtor trying to attract
person to visit an open house or it could
be an online app trying to get me to
the store and try a new pair of sneakers.
The first thing that were identifying and
exploring is the fact that by
giving information,
we're lending ourselves to be targeted.
And in a sense, that information can
be used against us by the other party.
[MUSIC]
A big question in marketing is
that of truth in advertising.
Now, that's central to marketing.
Can we trust sellers and what they claim?
Even the Federal Trade Commission
allows advertisers to engage in what
they call persuasive puffery
to puff up their attributes,
to claim that they have
the best burgers in town or
that they have the most trendy shirts or
whatever you want.
When in reality,
this is always a little hard to judge.
These are subjective claims.
But if they're sort of reasonably
sort of expected claims,
expected exaggerations, well,
that turns out to be legal.
That creates a very interesting
interaction with personalized advertising.
Because if I have that leeway to convey
the exact attributes that you care about,
I can customize my message to make it
the most appealing to you as possible.
At the same time as consumers
understand that this is happening,
that's the genesis of
the credibility issue.
They understand that the ads have
been tailored to their tastes.
And so now, that creates a mistrust
between consumers and advertisers.
They understand that advertisers have
that leeway to customize their message,
to make it the most attractive possible.
And so, sometimes reported low
credibility that advertisers already
have with consumers is in peril
of becoming even less credible.
[MUSIC]
So in an age where data is almost free and
it's becoming so easy to collect data,
how should we think about what is best for
advertisers?
Should they get better data or not?
And what is best for consumers?
For companies, best practices are to
always inform customers of the data that
they are collecting about consumers and
that is a good thing for companies.
We usually think,
why would companies want to disclose that?
Well, it turns out consumers will
appreciate the fact that there's clear
privacy policies and
there's clear data disclosure policies.
And companies like Google, Facebook,
Amazon now have that
type of information and
you can access your personal information
that they're collecting about you.
[MUSIC]
On the consumer front,
should I share my personal
information with advertiser or not?
Well, it turns out we
find a falling effect.
If these are mainstream preferences like,
I would like a spacious house or
a family friendly car,
those sort of mainstream preferences.
Most people have those preferences.
It turns out, we don't benefit quite
a lot from giving off that information.
If anything, we can get sales people
now pitching us back our tastes.
However, if our tastes are very specific,
if there's something we would really like
to find or we would like to be found by.
So maybe I like this particular
type genre of comic book or
this particular type of music
that very few people like or
there's very few artists playing, then I
would like to be found by those people.
And so those are the situations where I
would like to give off information and
disclose my likes and dislikes are in
settings where my tastes are really
not representative, but
they're really sort of niche type tastes.
[MUSIC]
In a sense, an ironic finding
of our paper is that better
information can be worse for
advertisers, which is really surprising.
It's a perverse effect.
I get better information about consumers.
This is all what managers talk about,
sort of this big data revolution and
I can become worse off.
Because consumers are understanding
that firms are taking advantage
of this data to personalize their
messages, to target them and
they're not likely to respond in
a positive way to these type of ads.
And consumers and firms, do we have
only two ways to build about this.
And particular managers can either
decide not to gather to much data about
consumers, which is hard to impose.
Or at the very least,
disclose how those that are being used.
And so if I'm seeing an ad,
if I'm targeted with an ad,
I would like to know why
I'm getting this ad.
Getting rid of that uncertainty for
consumers is useful.
Because now, they can make the call.
They can understand.
Well, okay,
this firm has this data about me.
They want to recommend me this product,
but
it's up to me whether I want to pay
attention to that call to action or not.
[MUSIC]